everybody's commenting on my music
um that is the Dutton Ranch freestyle
now we talk about crypto creep Sam
bankman freed he's begging for mercy
after losing billions of customers money
now the frogster's family is reportedly
calling the rat infested Bahamas prison
where he is being held and asking if he
could get some vegan meals
it's unclear whether or not that request
has been granted but while all the talk
is about Sam what's going on with his
former flame Caroline Ellison Bateman
freed has blamed her for the collapse of
the FDX crypto exchange she hasn't been
charged so rumors are swirling that she
flipped on her former boyfriend
and how rich is this members of Congress
who are supposed to get to the bottom of
the fraud well they took Sam's Dirty
Money bangman freed and his FTX cronies
pumped in nearly 95 000 in donations to
at least 11 lawmakers who serve on the
committee investigating last month's
collapse of the FTX crypto exchange I
hope you don't mind me saying this
sander during the commercial break you
said hey this isn't a Madoff thing this
isn't a contest what is it I don't
really get the comparisons to this being
a Ponzi scheme it really isn't I mean a
Ponzi scheme is you take you know the
First Investors in a Ponzi scheme and
you take the the new investors and you
pay off the the original investors and
and that you got to keep raising money
continues for a long period of time this
was outright fraud this was outright
theft
um there's no reason why authorities
shouldn't have caught on to what he was
doing earlier I also said during the
commercial break if we're going to go
there the sdny this week that new news
conference we covered it during America
reports was flabbergasting these were
the these prosecutors stood up there
like somehow they discovered this this
case was handed to them on a platter
with a bow they did not discover this
and you have to ask yourself in the wake
of all these donations to Democrats yeah
there were some Republicans but mostly
to Democrats you have to look at this
and you have to ask yourself why is this
a market that continues with without the
regulations that most asset classes have
they have rules they have regulations
why was this exempt from that why is
this still exempt from that and why do
we have to beg for that to happen this
should have never happened there were
red flags all along the way and now we
need to hold accountable all those who
turn to Blind Eye to this because a lot
of people have had their livelihoods
wiped out as a result of this and the
FEDS didn't catch this one they're
patting themselves on the back this week
that was remarkable
I want a classic Jesse Waters take on
why asking for vegan meals in prison is
perfectly reasonable reasonable
when you're
rich white Stanford Professor parents
called the jail and asked the warden if
you could change your meals because you
have dietary restrictions you cannot
recover from that this is not sleep away
camp
this guy is not in first class where
you're like oh you know I'll have the
vegan entree no this guy is in jail he
will be in jail forever and he needs to
get the cash back that he's still
squirreled away and give it back to
these people that he stole money from
and the girlfriend it looks like is
going to flip and sing and that's what
happens when you have a harem there's no
loyalty the Republicans they keep saying
oh the Republicans got so much money I'm
so sick of hearing that
if you could zoom in on this here see
the blue the blue are the Democratic
donations the red or the Republican
donations it's not even close and if you
add in all the money that the executives
at that firm donated that's about 70
million dollars that's about two Senate
seats the Democrats spent
and stole and I'm gonna claw that money
back from you and Geraldo because that
bet is bogus also if you get dirty money
from stolen cash and then you win an
election you can't just say I'm just
going to give it to charity right you oh
are you going to give it to the Clinton
Foundation you're going to give it to
your uncle's charity who's then just
going to donate it back to you next
cycle that is not fair to go to a victim
fund exactly and you can't have these
kamikazes
pump and dump
senates like you can't have guys
stealing cash donating it to Democrats
and then dying on the hill and they say
I'm just going to give the money to
charity you could do that every single
election if you wanted to one guy goes
to jail and they keep the Senate not
fair not fair Jessica
so we didn't steal the Senate
um USA steel purchased it with
fraudulent money
that's capitalism baby no it's not okay
I thought I would try
um so they should give back the money
and I don't think that the charity is
good enough I don't know how there
obviously needs to be someone in charge
of this who can make sure because a lot
of this money was given to huge packs
right that then distribute money to
various candidates various issues so I
don't know how that works but yes just
picking a charity you know animal
cruelty or whatever doesn't help the
people that need this money back so a
victim's fund makes complete sense to me
when you're in prison and you have a
reli a religious reason for why you need
a special meal that's one thing if this
is just a dietary preference that's not
good enough and they're definitely
vegetarian meals that are available I
understand it might not be you know what
you want
um the girlfriend is a very strange
piece of this puzzle for sure I don't
know about the Harem stuff to it and I
know there were multiple women around
but if she is going to flip on him great
um it continues to be one of the
craziest stories and just why watching
all of this erupt like on CNBC it's been
going wild today with people finally
attacking it's not that complicated he
just ripped a lot of people off I mean
that's just plain and simple vegan is it
pretty clear that his girlfriend is
singing well yeah let's talk about CNBC
where Jim Cramer referred to FTX as the
next JP Morgan their coverage of crypto
and everything about this company this
man has been and nauseating
embarrassment
um what did you just ask me the
girlfriend is singing yes she hired
Wilmer Hale she was spotted here in New
York City in lower Manhattan at a at a
coffee bar he was clearly throwing SPF
was throwing her under the bus pointing
the finger at heart she was running the
um the trading Division and all along
um that the trading division was the
customer money was being used at the
trading division right um that he the
money was being funneled over there and
he was is overseeing it even not when
his name wasn't on as CEO it's going to
it would make a very easy prosecution of
him if she gets on the witness hand
screw you know financial documents and
uh you know kind of digital information
and evidence just her testifying against
him would really be enough having
covered so many of these trials to
Sandra's Point what went on certainly
these um contributions to all of these
Democrats played into this but the
Federal Trade Commission could have
regulated this they regulate literally
anything to do with Consumer Fraud you
can't say that a bucket of paint covers
400 feet and it only covers 200 feet the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
Elizabeth Warren where are you uh
because you're only a lot of mouth and
no Mojo the Securities and Exchange
Commission the commodity Futures Trade
Commission the Department of Justice uh
directly gambling is more regulated than
any of this and it's all because nobody
wanted to stop the the trading of these
digital Beanie Babies everybody was
having a blast and making so much money
it's the reason that Tick Tock has never
been regulated and now everybody in DC
is woken up to it everybody was getting
rich and the Allure of crypto was always
and still is largely the fact that get
the government out of my money I hate
fiat currency get I want the
government's hands off my money well
guess what this is what happens when the
government's not involved in your money
it's just like the 1920s and that did
not end well
no let's hope it doesn't end like that
well it just did with this jacket with
this guy I hope not for the rest of us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else